David Boder: [In English] München, September the 20th, 1946, in a UNRRA transient camp in Funkenkasernen. The interviewee is Mr. Ernesto Moelller-Arnold, fifty-one years old, nacido de...born in Chile. I am beginning to mix the language.
David Boder: [In Spanish] Señor Moeller-Arnold, venga Ud. más próximo para que...[Ininteligible].
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí, estoy...estoy sentado bastante cómodo.
David Boder: Yo prefiero que hable Ud. en voz normal...
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí.
David Boder: . . . Entonces se recorda mejor. Haría Ud. el favor de decirnos otra vez cómo se nombra Ud., cómo es su nombre, cuántos años tiene, dónde nació.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Yo...mi nombre es Ernesto Moeller-Arnold y soy nacido en Santiago de Chile, en el año mil novecientos...1894.
David Boder: Sí. Y dígame...entonces ¿dónde estuvo Ud. Señor Arnold cuando comenzó la guerra?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Al comenzar la guerra, yo tenía un puesto como gerente de haciendas en...Alta Silesia, estaba administrando haciendas que pertenecían a gente que tenía a la vez sus haciendas en territorio polaco, en territorio checoslovaco y territorio alemán. Y, por consecuencia de eso, era muy difícil encontrar personas para administrarlas que tenían la confianza de todo, de todas partes.
David Boder: Ajá.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Una persona tal fui yo como chileno, como persona neutral, de un país muy lejano.
David Boder: Pues señor Arnold, dígame ¿cómo Ud. llegó a Europa en primer lugar? ¿Cuándo?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Yo la primera vez que llegué a Europa, yo llegué a Viena a estudiar...en la famosa...Hochschule der Bodenkultur. Ya, como me había decidido de aprender la agronomía.
David Boder: Sí. Y entonces, ¿se quedó Ud. en Europa desde entonces?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: No, yo volví a Chile y estuve un buen tiempo en Chile pero...durante la crisis mundial del ’28 que estalló en esos años, yo...no podía, no tenía los...el dinero bastante para comprarme una buena hacienda. Y como se me ofreció este...un puesto bueno en la Alta Silesia, dónde había conocido yo a gente de allá durante mi estudio en Viena, yo lo acepté.
David Boder: Bueno. Bueno, entonces, ¿quiénes eran dueños de esta hacienda en Alta Silesia?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Eran varios. Eran entre otros, la...la compañía minera (ininteligible) en Gleiwitz, la compañía minera Godula en Katowice, la compañía minera Henkel Limited en Londres, y...
David Boder: Entonces ¿cómo...fueron...fueron haciendas agrícolas?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Eran haciendas que pertenecían a esas compañías y que esas compañías tenían para alimentar a sus trabajadores, que tenían...
David Boder: ¿Qué tenían en sus minas?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí.
David Boder: ¡Oh! Bueno, entonces, ¿Ud. administraba esas haciendas de qué año?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Desde el año ’29...’29, ’30, ’31, ’32.
David Boder: Bueno. ¿Y hasta qué tiempo?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Hasta el último momento, hasta el...enero ’45 cuando esas haciendas fueron ocupadas por el ejército ruso.
David Boder: Ajá. Bueno, entonces dígame señor, ¿dónde estuvo Ud. cuando comenzó la guerra?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Yo estuve en Alta Silesia, justamente ahí dónde trabajaba.
David Boder: Sí, bueno. ¿Y...qué le pasó durante la guerra?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Durante la guerra no me pasó mucho, yo tuve muchas dificultades con las autoridades alemanas sobre todo con las autoridades militares.
David Boder: Sí.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Esas dificultades al estallar la guerra no fueron muy grandes porque al fin y al cabo se necesitaba algo de comer para la gente y por eso me dejaron al principio en paz.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Pero como yo me empeñaba también a proteger gente perseguida y...como yo me empeñaba sobre todo de alimentar tanto mejor posible a los trabajadores que traían como prisioneros extranjeros y a...garantizarles mejores raciones, tuve bastantes dificultades con lo tipos que gobernaban en ese tiempo.
David Boder: Ajá. Bueno, dígame, de modo que para trabajar en su hacienda, las haciendas a su cargo, le trajeron...es...obreros extranjeros.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: No, no. Los obreros extranjeros trabajaban en las minas.
David Boder: Ajá.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Y yo tenía que...
David Boder: ¡Oh! [Ininteligible]
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Que...encargarme de...
David Boder: Sí.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: . . . de darles de comer, no directamente sino de...de entregar los víveres necesarios a las cocinas y a las cantinas que los alimentaban.
David Boder: ¿Qué...ellos vivían qué...en lagers, en barraks? ¿Cómo vivían?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Era diferente, parte de ellos vivía en barracas y en lagers, y parte de ellos vivía...vivía en...privadamente.
David Boder: Ubicados en casas privadas. Pues, dígame señor, entonces...¿qué clase de gente tuvo Ud.... tuvieron ellos para trabajar en las minas? ¿De qué nacionalidad? ¿De qué religión?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Tenían gente de casi toda nacionalidad. Tenían prisioneros ingleses, tenían gente de todos los países, pero la mayor parte eran ucranianos que trajeron de la Rusia.
David Boder: Gente ucraniana, ¿mujeres también?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Mujeres, no. En las minas no he visto mujeres en ese tiempo...
David Boder: Ajá.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: . . . allá.
David Boder: Bueno, y...indirectamente Ud. tuvo la responsabilidad de la alimentación. Bueno, ¿y quién trabajó en los campos en sus haciendas?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: En los campos trabajaron...quedaron la mayor parte de los trabajadores que habían trabajado antes. Trabajaron también en los tiempos de guerra porque...la mayor parte en la Alta Silesia de trabajadores son las mujeres...
David Boder: Ajá.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Los hombres se van a las minas y las mujeres quedan en las haciendas, así ya era mucho tiempo antes de la guerra.
David Boder: Y esa es la tradición. Bueno, y entonces cuando...llegó el ejército ruso, entonces ¿qué pasó?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí. Cuando llegó el ejército ruso fuimos primeramente evacuados de allá todos los que habitábamos ahí por los alemanes. Nos mandaron a Turingia.
David Boder: Sí. ¿Y dónde los pusieron en Turingia?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Yo me...dejé mi familia en Turingia que fue metida en una aldea allá, en muy mal alojamiento, pero como yo quería tratar de continuar mi trabajo también con los rusos, yo volví a Silesia.
David Boder: Sí. ¿Y entonces qué pasó?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Yo encontré las haciendas más o menos todas devastadas y destruidas con...sobre todo habían arrastrado a todas las máquinas, a todos los caballos.
David Boder: Ajá.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Y las...haciendas mismas estaban confiscadas por las autoridades polacas.
David Boder: Ajá. ¿Las confiscaron para distribuirlas entre la gente como ejidos?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí, dijeron que querían distribuirlas pero...yo quedé más o menos, tratando de...seguir mi trabajo, más con una ayuda muy amable por parte de los polacos. No puedo quejarme de ellos, pero como no había ningún medio para trabajar, era imposible hacer algo y solamente sentarse como jefe ahí sin...sin verdadero trabajo. Yo no quería seguir, era una farsa lo que hacía.
David Boder: ¿Dónde está su familia ahora Don Ernesto?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Mi familia está también en el campamento aquí conmigo.
David Boder: ¿En el campamento de UNRRA, aquí? Bueno. Ahora dígame, ¿entonces cómo...cuando se separó Ud. de esas haciendas y de los rusos?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí, los rusos me dijeron francamente y netamente que yo como extranjero, de nacionalidad americana, para los rusos no tenía que ver nada más allá, sino que tenía que volver a mi país natal.
David Boder: Bueno.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Y...
David Boder: [Ininteligible].
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Trataron de despacharme primero vía Odessa, como a muchos otros extranjeros franceses y belgas, con qué estaba junto.
David Boder: Sí. ¿Cómo dice que estaba junto? ¿Qué le pusieron en un lager?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: No, no, habitaba. Y a los belgas y franceses estaban...los habían encerrado en campamentos, allá.
David Boder: Y a Ud....
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Pero yo al principio no estuve en...en campamento. Me trataron de persuadir de irme a un campamento allá, pero como me dijeron que iban a repatriarme vía Odessa...
David Boder: Sí.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Eso me parecía un poco extraño.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Y yo me puse en camino primero por mi propia cuenta...
David Boder: Sí.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Con algunos belgas también que no creían a esa repatriación vía Odessa.
David Boder: Ajá. Bueno, su familia estuvo en Turingia, de modo que estuvo Ud. solo y no tuvo mucha dificultad de marchar.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: No.
David Boder: ¿Entonces cómo se salió Ud. de allá?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Yo salí con nuevos prisioneros belgas que marchamos juntos...
David Boder: ¿Ilegalmente?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Ilegalmente. No tuvimos muchas dificultades por parte de los rusos hasta me ayudaron...
David Boder: Um.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: . . . de vez en cuando, y me marché con ellos hasta la Turingia.
David Boder: Ajá. De modo, ¿cuánto tiempo marcharon Ud. por territorio polaco o ruso?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí, eso no me recuerdo bien, pero a lo menos unos, desde Alta Silesia hasta...hasta...hasta donde lo dejé...hasta Wurzen en Sajonia...
David Boder: Sí.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: . . . empleé unas tres semanas más o menos.
David Boder: Ajá. Y...
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Y a veces en camión, a veces de a pie, a veces en...
David Boder: En...en...
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: . . . por ferrocarril, en carros de papa.
David Boder: ¿Tuvo Ud. algo de dinero?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: No, el dinero me lo quitaron soldados en el camino que estaban pillando.
David Boder: ¿Cómo...le...le buscaron...?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí, había siempre soldados que hacían sus propios negocios por allá.
David Boder: Ajá.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: De todas las naciones que había.
David Boder: Soldados de todas las naciones.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí, pero esos ¡lástima! eran rusos.
David Boder: Ajá. Bueno...
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Buenos amigos rusos.
David Boder: Sí, entonces llegó Ud. a Turingia. ¿Y cómo de Turingia llegó Ud. para acá, para este campo?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: En Turingia, las autoridades rusas, por su parte, declararon otra vez que teníamos que dejar su zona.
David Boder: Ajá.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Y yo reuní a mi familia y entré en un campamento ruso, y fui transportado por los rusos a la zona americana y entregado a la UNRRA americana por los rusos mismos.
David Boder: ¡Oh! Del campamento ruso, bueno. ¿Y la UNRRA lo trajo para acá?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: La UNRRA me mandó para acá.
David Boder: ¿Y Turingia es en la región rusa?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Turingia es región rusa.
David Boder: Ajá.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Al principio era región americana pero desde principios de julio de 1945 es región rusa.
David Boder: Entonces lo mandaron para acá. Bueno, ahora ¿cuánto tiempo ya está Ud. aquí?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Oh, casi un año.
David Boder: ¿Y por qué le toma tanto tiempo?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Porque hasta ahora no dejaron salir a ningún sudamericano de acá oficialmente. Se pudieron marchar solamente la gente que se marchó negra, y un...padre de familia no puede marcharse negro.
David Boder: ¡Oh! Negro...Ud. llama a...el camino ilegal.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí.
David Boder: Ajá. Bueno, ¿cuántas personas son en su familia?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Yo tengo cinco niños, menores de edad.
David Boder: Y su esposa.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Y mi esposa, sí.
David Boder: ¿Es chilena su esposa?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: No, es de descendencia danesa.
David Boder: ¿Qué?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Danesa.
David Boder: ¿Danesa? ¿Se casó Ud. aquí en Europa?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí, me casé en Europa.
David Boder: ¡Oh! Bueno, dígame, y...si se va Ud. ahora para Chile ¿quién paga su...su transporte?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Yo podría...habría podido pagarlo, a lo menos...veinte veces con los dineros que tenía a mi disposición, pero como parte de ello se ha perdido y la otra parte no vale nada...
David Boder: ¿Qué dinero es?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Es dinero alemán porque todo el otro dinero fue confiscado por los alemanes...por los alemanes, que tenía todavía en Sudamérica...
David Boder: Sí.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Me quedó solamente...
David Boder: ¿Su dinero que Ud. tuvo en Sudamérica...?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: En Sudamérica.
David Boder: . . . ¿fue confiscado?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí, fue confiscado por las [ininteligible] alemanas.
David Boder: Espérese, Ud. tuvo Americ...dinero en Chile.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Tenía dinero en Chile, sí.
David Boder: Bueno, entonces ¿qué pueden los alemanes decir sobre su dinero en Chile?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí, podían, exigían una declaración de los bienes que uno tenía en el extranjero, bajo juramento.
David Boder: Sí.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Y ese dinero fue...para esos dineros...ofrecieron en cambio...
David Boder: Marks.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Marks, y...se lo llevaron.
David Boder: Bueno, pero Ud. estuvo ciudadano chileno.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí, no importaba.
David Boder: ¿El cónsul no podía defenderlo de ningún modo?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: No, no podía defenderlo porque...todo lo que pertenec...lo que estaba aquí en el...en el territorio alemán estaba sujeto a las leyes alemanas como me declaraban y no podía evitarlo.
David Boder: Pero miré, parece que Chile estuvo en la guerra de parte de los Aliados, ¿no?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí, pero declaró la guerra...
David Boder: Más tarde.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: . . . el 12 de abril ’45.
David Boder: ¡Oh! Tan tarde. De modo...(risas)...de modo que...antes ellos podían tener...tomar su dinero.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: No, desde ’43, había las relaciones diplomáticas...
David Boder: Interrumpidas.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Estaban interrumpidas.
David Boder: Entonces, ¿cómo se llegaron a su dinero?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: No...mm...¿a mi dinero?
David Boder: [Ininteligible]
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: No, eso lo habían confiscado ya antes.
David Boder: ¿Antes?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí.
David Boder: Entonces, bueno ¿qué? ¿la UNRRA le paga el pasaje a la gente?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: No, no creemos que la UNRRA vaya a pagar pasaje para nosotros, contamos...que nuestro gobierno nos va a ayudar.
David Boder: Bueno, ¿sabe Ud. algo todavía de su gobierno?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: No, sé muy poco porque hasta ahora era muy difícil ponerse en comunicación con nuestro gobierno.
David Boder: ¿No tiene consulado chileno en Alemania?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: No hay todavía consulado chileno en Alemania.
David Boder: Entonces, ¿el consulado más próximo es dónde?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: El...los consulados más próximos están en Zurich y en París.
David Boder: En París. ¿Y qué, tienen algún representante que los vino a ver aquí o...?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: No, hasta ahora nadie.
David Boder: ¿Cuántos chilenos hay aquí en este campo?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: En este campo hay setenta y seis chilenos.
David Boder: ¡¿Setenta y seis chilenos?!
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí.
David Boder: ¡Es un número bastante grande!
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí, porque están reunidos casi todos de la zona americana aquí.
David Boder: Bueno, dígame otra cosa. De modo que Ud. estuvo una persona relativamente libre en Alemania durante la guerra. ¿Cómo Ud. aprecia toda la situación? Ud. conocía alemanes y tuvo amigos alemanes o...
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí.
David Boder: Bueno. ¿Qué...cuál fue la...opinión...la actitud, por decir así, de ellos sobre todo lo que pasaba aquí en Alemania durante la guerra?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí, en...yo conozco sobre todo la situación como se...se puede entender en Alta Silesia porque estuve en Alta Silesia.
David Boder: Sí, bueno.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: En Alta Silesia.
David Boder: Alta Silesia es un poco polaco.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí, Alta Silesia es una cosa que...una cosa por sí.
David Boder: Sí, bueno dígame.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: No se puede considerar como representante, digamos de toda la mentalidad alemana porque...digamos...hablan entre sí, hablan el polaco...
David Boder: Um.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Y entre ellos es claro que la...una buena parte de ellos no tenía muchas ganas de participar en la guerra y...eran hostiles a...a todo lo que se pasaba...
David Boder: Bueno.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: A toda la política, justamente porque se consideraban...medio polacos.
David Boder: Ajá. Bueno, estuvo allá...un grupo que se consideraba Reichsdeutsch.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: ¡Sí! Pero no había muchos. La gente que venía allá sobre todo como digamos...como ingenieros de minas, venía de Westphalia.
David Boder: Sí.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Y era gente católica que estaba también en una cierta oposición, como Alta Silesia es un país muy buen católico...
David Boder: Um. Entonces.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Ellos nunca querían eh...trabajar con los prusianos que no eran católicos.
David Boder: Ajá.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Y preferían a sacarse la gente de Westphalia y como la gente de Westphalia es también gente minera...
David Boder: Sí.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: . . . eso estaba muy en orden.
David Boder: Ajá. Pues, dígame señor, ¿Ud. sabe la situación en que se encontró el pueblo judío? Pues usted como una persona de lado, como de observador. ¿Qué sabe Ud. de está situación y cómo la aprecia Ud.?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí. La...
David Boder: Francamente.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: La situación del pueblo judío fue terrible. No teníamos lejos de allá el campamento de...el campamento de Auschwitz.
David Boder: Ajá.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Nunca se sabía algo de lo que se pasaba allá, verdaderamente estaba muy bien isolado.
David Boder: Sí.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Pero se sabía eso, que...la gente fue tratada muy mal y sufrieron bastante los pobrecitos que...que fueron transportados por allá y que nosotros vimos que fueron transportados. No vimos mucho porque esos transportes siempre se pasaban o por la noche o por caminos que uno no podía observar.
David Boder: Um.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Corrían solamente bolas sobre ellos y uno no sabía lo que era verdad y lo que era exagerado, pero sabíamos bastante que sufrían.
David Boder: Bueno, allá próximo de Auschwitz estuvo Birkenau, ¿no?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí, Birkenau no está lejos.
David Boder: Bueno, dicen que en Birkenau se encontraban los crematorios y que...se pusieron allá a la gente...en las cámaras de gas y todo. ¿Se sabían en...la gente allá cercana, se sabía que se hacen esas cosas en Birkenau?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: No, en nuestra región, dónde yo trabajaba, estaba más o menos a...digamos...50 Km. de Auschwitz.
David Boder: Sí.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Y ahí verdaderamente no se sabía nada de las cámaras de gas y de esos crematorios. Se sabía solamente que llevaban mucha gente por allá y dónde quedaba no se sabía exactamente nada.
David Boder: Bueno, no había gente que...
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sabíamos solamente que la gente por ejemplo que...trabajaba...había también judíos por ejemplo, que trabajaban en los caminos allá.
David Boder: Sí.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Y que esos fueron tratados muy mal, eso lo sabíamos, porque eso lo veíamos. Eso se podía observar, mientras tanto que todo lo otro, solamente se oía de vez en cuando un rumor pero más no.
David Boder: Ajá. Bueno, ¿no hubo alemanes, polacos que trabajaban en Auschwitz que tenían...que estuvieron allá de soldados y eso...que se regresaban y decían algo de esto?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: No...por nuestra parte yo no hemos encontrado tales soldados, puede ser que...yo no sé si los impidieron a ponerse en contacto con el...
David Boder: [Ininteligible]
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: . . . Con el resto del mundo, o cómo lo hicieron pero...
David Boder: Sí.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: . . . No me recuerdo de tal cosa. Sé solamente que se hablaba de que se llevaba a la gente allá y lo que yo mismo he visto son gente que sufría mucho bajo condiciones de trabajo...monstruosas, en los caminos.
David Boder: Y la...
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: En una...exactamente en una vía ferroviaria donde lo pudo...lo pude observar.
David Boder: ¿Puede Ud. describir un poco lo que yo...lo que Ud. ha visto?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí, yo he visto que la gente trabajaba en...con...muy mala alimentada y eso...es lo que sobre todo se podía ver y que era...tenían...cabos que los trataban bastante mal.
David Boder: ¿Cabos?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí.
David Boder: ¿Los maltrataban físicamente?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí, eso también se veía de vez en cuando, no mucho, pero se veía de vez en cuando que los maltrataban.
David Boder: Bueno. Ud...
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Bastaba para una persona que tiene un sentimiento humano, bastaba.
David Boder: Bastaba. ¿Ud. estuvo próximo de Katowice, Sosnowiec?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Digamos, entre Katowice y Gleiwitz.
David Boder: Katowice y Gleiwitz.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí.
David Boder: Sería próximo de dónde Ud. estuvo. Bueno, ¿Ud. supo que las ciudades como Katowice o Sosnowiec que se construyeron los guetos?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: En Katowice no sé que había gueto. No había gueto en Katowice, creo que llevaron a los judíos a...
David Boder: [Ininteligible] A otro lugar.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: A otro lugar.
David Boder: Sí. A Katowice lo declar...lo hicieron...cómo se llama...Judenrein.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí.
David Boder: Sí. Y...
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Allá no había judíos.
David Boder: Sí, no había judíos desde el advenimiento de Hitler. Bueno, ahora, los otros chilenos que tiene Ud. aquí ¿qué clase de gente son, cómo ellos llegaron para acá?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí, es muy diferente. Entre ellos hay gente que vino para curarse, por ejemplo uno, que tenía una enfermedad terrible de sus ojos.
David Boder: Sí.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Muchos estaban aquí para estudiar porque...era usual de mandar sus hijos y sus niños a Europa.
David Boder: ¿De Chile?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: De Chile, algún tiempo a lo menos. No todo el tiempo, sino unos dos, tres años a Europa.
David Boder: Sí.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Y otros que vinieron por acá para visitar a sus parientes.
David Boder: Ajá.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Tenían padres...o...
David Boder: Um.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: . . . abuelos aquí que querían visitar, aquí o en Austria y en Europa Central.
David Boder: Ajá.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Y también gente que estaba justamente aquí por sus negocios, por ejemplo trabajando, perfeccionándose como ingeniero y cosa tal, para emplear lo que habían aprendido en su patria.
David Boder: ¿Cómo? ¿Los forzaron de entrar al ejército? ¿Estuvo en el ejército?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: A una...a algunos de ellos, a algunos jóvenes de ellos...seguramente los forzaron a entrar al ejército, aunque algunos podían evitarlo.
David Boder: Ajá.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Pero pocos supieron evitarlo. Los que tenemos aquí son sobre todo...hay pocos jóvenes, entre ellos muchachos, son sobre todo niñas que tenemos aquí, algunos pocos jóvenes.
David Boder: Sí.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Tenemos también algunos que...primero estuvieron en el ejército pero lograron salir otra vez de él y encontraron un empleo en el país mismo.
David Boder: Um. Bueno, y...ellos se...hay algunos que son medio alemanes, medio chilenos.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Hay gente, sobre todo de seguro, es gente de descendencia alemana a lo menos.
David Boder: Sí. ¿Los hubo mucho en Chile?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: No, hay bastante gente de descendencia alemana sobre todo en el sur de Chile que fue colonizado por gente de...
David Boder: ¡Oh!
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: . . . de descendencia alemana. En Valdivia, Osorno, Temuco, son ciudades donde uno encuentra muchos nombres alemanes.
David Boder: Pues allá parece que estuvieron en América del Sur ciudadanos muy buenos, muy útiles.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí, claro, hasta el estallido de la guerra esa gente tenía muy buen renombre en Chile y nunca se metió en la política chilena y...disturbó la política. Tampoco durante la guerra yo no he oído nada de eso y, por eso, tampoco hubo grandes canjes como las hubo por ejemplo en las Americas Centrales.
David Boder: Sí. Pues dígame, Ud. dice que salió de Chile ¿en qué año?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: ’28.
David Boder: ’28. Bueno, entonces...aquel tiempo ¿y vino Ud. para Alemania...para Silesia en este tiempo?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Yo vine primero a Austria en ese tiempo.
David Boder: Ajá.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Y después tuve mi domicilio en el país que...podía juzgarse que era un país por el cual se peleaba todo el mundo.
David Boder: ¿Qué era?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Alta Silesia.
David Boder: Alta Silesia, ¿pero en aquel tiempo esto estuvo en las manos de quién? ¿De los checos?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Parte pertenecía a los checos, parte pertenecía a los polacos y parte a los alemanes, y tenían una jurisdicción especial.
David Boder: Sí.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Estaban...pertenecían a esos estados pero estaba restricta esa...
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: . . . soberanía por leyes administrativas sobre todo y leyes económicas sobre todo. Por ejemplo, no necesitaba pagar impuesto para algunos productos que canjeaban...
David Boder: Ajá.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: . . . de un lado al otro.
David Boder: Dígame esto, Ud. es agricultor ¿cómo le parece a Ud. la agricultura alemana ha sufrido mucho durante la guerra?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Yo conozco solamente, porque no se podía hacer viajes durante la guerra, la agricultura en Alta Silesia.
David Boder: Ajá.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Y esa, se puede decir está destruida.
David Boder: ¿Eso por qué? ¿Se llevaron las máquinas o los animales, o qué?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Se llevó todo lo que había que se podía llevar, los animales y las máquinas y las siembras, todo lo que había, se desapareció.
David Boder: Ajá.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Y las batallas no hicieron gran daño y tampoco los raids aéreos hicieron allá gran daño porque no hubo muchos raids. Los rusos no hicieron...
David Boder: Raids.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Ataques aéreos.
David Boder: Sí.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Pero...el fin de la guerra hizo el mayor daño.
David Boder: Bueno, y por lo que Ud. tuvo la oportunidad, Ud. habla alemán, tuvo Ud. la oportunidad de hablar con los alemanes ahora, ¿cuál es el sentimiento? ¿Qué creen ellos que pasará con Alemania?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí, yo conozco entre los alemanes, conozco sobre todo la gente Silesiaca que fue echada afuera de Silesia. Ellos no tienen otro sentimiento que el deseo de volver a su patria nativa dónde estuvieron...
David Boder: ¿A Silesia?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: A Silesia, sí.
David Boder: ¿Y quieren volverse a Silesia?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Quisieran volver a Silesia dónde...
David Boder: ¿Y por qué no vuelven?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Porque...porque según los tratados ahora fueron desplazados por los polacos, los echaron afuera.
David Boder: Ud. dice de la gente que se consideraba alemana.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Los polacos consideran a todos los que habitaban antes allá, como alemanes.
David Boder: Alemanes.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Bueno, no tomaron parte en el...
David Boder: ¿No pasó esto que Hitler importó a muchos alemanes a Silesia durante la guerra?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: No, porque Silesia estaba bastante poblada también durante...
David Boder: Ajá.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Y ya antes no había lugar para importar alemanes. Los alemanes que fueron importados, fueron importados en...en Wartagau...y cómo se llamaba...en la provincia Posen y allá, allá, metieron alemanes...
David Boder: Sí.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Pero en Silesia no llevaron ni una persona, no había ni un metro cuadrado para esta gente.
David Boder: ¿Y dónde está ahora esa gente?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Esos están sobre todo en la zona rusa, en la parte alemana de la zona rusa y en la zona británica y algunos también, quizás unos cien mil, estarán en la zona americana.
David Boder: ¡¿Unos cien mil?! ¿Pues cuántos ellos expulsaron?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Expulsaron a ver...a más o menos la Silesia estaba habitada por más o menos siete millones de personas, todos fueron expulsados. Ahora queda solamente, más o menos un millón pero que...
David Boder: Que se consideraban verdaderamente polacos.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: No, es que quieren expulsar todavía. Toda la gente fue expulsada...
David Boder: [Ininteligible]
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Hasta el último de Silesia, sí.
David Boder: ¿Y qué...cuando los expulsan les dan algo de su propiedad, les dan algo de...?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Los que fueron expulsados hasta ahora, fueron expulsados como pobrecitos, sin nada.
David Boder: Pues se dice que Sudeten, por ejemplo, los expulsan a los alemanes que hay una comisión que vea que les dan a cada uno cincuenta kilos tanto de...de su propie...de efectos personales y todo. ¿Pero no se hizo lo mismo en Silesia?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: En Silesia, hasta el año pasado o hasta este año, lo que he oído, lo que me contó la gente silesiaca que he hablado, no pudo llevar nada.
David Boder: Bueno, entonces, ¿a quién ellos culpan? ¿A Hitler o a los...polacos?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Los sentimientos en...por...
David Boder: ¿Por los rusos?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: . . . por los rusos y los polacos no son muy amables porque fueron tratados bastante mal por ellos.
David Boder: Sí.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Y es claro que el que trata mal...
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: . . . tiene que pagarlo con malos sentimientos.
David Boder: Sí, claro, pero por otro modo ellos pueden...podrían pensar o entender, si Hitler no hubiera comenzado todo...
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Eso es claro, eso se dice la gente la gente que piensa, pero la mayoría de la gente no piensa sino sufre solamente en el momento y ve al que le hace sufrir y eso es una cosa que hace bastante daño. Uno puede pegar a un otro y decirle “Hitler tiene la culpa porque me pegó a mí,” pero él al que pega siempre ve solamente al que está delante de sí, no ve a las causas que están más lejanas.
David Boder: Pues esa es una observación muy interesante Don Ernesto, porque a veces nosotros pensamos si la humanidad hubiera aprendido alguna lección de toda esta catástrofe, ¿qué piensa Ud.?
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: Sí, la lección que debiera aprender es simplemente acabar un día con las hostilidades y uno tiene que empezar por acabar, porque s iempre cuando se...se va pagando la cuenta, eso continúa hasta el último juicio.
David Boder: Pues Don Ernesto, muchísimas gracias. Yo quisiera tener algún reporte, información, de persona que estuvo en Alemania durante todo el tiempo y que podía observar las cosas un poco como un extranjero. Yo creo que a todos nos interesará mucho estudiar lo que Ud. a dicho.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool 135. The interviewee was Don Ernesto Moeller-Arnold, a Chilean by birth who spent during the time of the war in Germany as a manager of various etstates, agricultural properties, and had some opportunity to observer...had some opportunity to observe—I am mixing my Spanish with my English—what has happened. Muenchen, September the 20th, 1946. Spool 135, Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording. Thank you very much, Mr. Moeller.
Ernesto Moeller-Arnold: [In Spanish] No hay de qué, señor.